The latch tool is most commonly used
to reverse stitches,
turning knit stitches into purl stitches.
Notice how the purl bump is showing
against the knit stitches in this example.
To reform an existing stitch,
push the tool into a stitch below the one
that's currently in work on a needle.
Drop the stitch off the needle
and ravel it, forming a ladder.
Use the tool to pick up each ladder,
forming new stitches.
To create a column of reformed stitches,
drop a single stitch,
pick up each ladder, forming new stitches.
When the last strand has been knit,
rehang the stitch on the needle.
Now you have a column
of reformed stitches.
This can be done across a row
for a turning row or a manually
formed decorative purl row.
Anytime you use a latch tool, remember,
you're positioning a needle
in the opposite direction
of the needles on the needle bed.
If you reform stitches,
they will be facing the opposite way.
Think about knit and purl
stitches as in hand knitting.